all right everyone bang-bang
we've got Cameron here I'm super excited
about this conversation thanks for doing
this man yeah no problem
I'm excited to be chiming in from a
nicer setting than where I'm usually out
in New York so we were just talking
Cameron is on a month-long road trip and
is currently with some friends in North
Carolina and they took all of the the
prime real estate to do real work so him
and I are going to chat while he sits
outside with a beautiful backdrop there
yeah yeah yeah I think that I think
they're deceived in terms of what prime
real estate is but that's okay
absolutely let's start with just your
background for those that don't know you
kind of what would you do before you got
to Ali Ali Corp yeah so I guess a little
bit of a divergent background in terms
of the traditional path if there is one
into venture capital side of things
studied study computer science in school
thought I was going to go down the
entrepreneurial path had worked on kind
of launching consulting firm in college
ended up dropping out though my senior
year and got drafted into the MLS so
played for a couple years in Montreal
and then in Kansas City working on the
side as an engineer with actually I
molest front office at the same time
doing some data engineering stuff there
had my body just completely fall apart
blew out a knee broke a leg and once he
kind of break both of your your legs you
really need to find something to do
sitting down
so I decided PC was a natural fit so I
ended up back in New York met Kevin Ryan
the founder of Valley Corp and kind of
have helped him and Wendy build this
this institution and venture studio
slash capital fund in New York City cool
and so has a leak or actually work I
think people here they fund they found
you know there's all these terminologies
time around but just kind of like what
goes on there every day
yeah so it's definitely a unique
institution especially in terms of how
it operates now as an evergreen fund so
we don't we don't have Bell Keys anymore
but the a bit of the backstory can help
contextualize it so it was started by
Kevin Ryan and Dwight Merriman after
double-click was sold to Google and they
started it initially as a way for them
to gain what what they called
entrepreneurial leverage so they they
wanted to be able to start a series of
companies without committing to any one
of them and this was around 2007-2008 in
I think they were probably at the
cutting edge of what would be called the
venture studio movement so over the
course of those first few years they
started what have now become fairly
brand name companies the [ __ ] DS guilt
groups Business Insider's Zola's so part
of that earlier batch and as those
companies have exited the the fund has
grown and expanded from just being a
place where we start 2 to 3 companies
every year to one where we also are
doing seed in series a investing
primarily in the New York ecosystem our
real goal is to kind of continue to grow
and foster that that environment and
hopefully get to the point where it's
it's really competitive with San
Francisco but it's a it's definitely
unique place where we we try to develop
concepts across verticals we have no
specific area we want to be doing a lot
of it's curiosity-driven and we come up
with the idea and if we can develop a
narrative that's compelling enough bring
on a founding team and fund it for the
first year or two to really get it going
it's very cool and any specific projects
that you're more excited than than
others or was you spending more time on
in terms of what you guys are building
yeah yeah so I can give you kind of a
sneak peak and some of this stuff that's
coming out of the pipeline I mean we've
been it's been fascinating to see our
blast especially quarantine being kind
of isolated I think this like deep
thinking has actually been much more
productive for us and not being
distracted by the whole city but some of
the areas where we're really excited to
start launching companies and as one
we're getting involved in the digital
therapeutics movement I think that
people or who are familiar with the FDA
and what they're doing in terms of
software only medical devices some of
the canonical examples being the mottos
Levon goes the pair of therapeutics we
think there's kind of a lot of
regulatory arbitrage there and also a
lot of opportunities to help in
behavioral management especially for
various types of addiction therapy so
we're going to start pushing that
forward and we're also doing stuff and
like I said we're incredibly generalist
and what we do on
we're working on a concept essentially
in the mobile food space we're trying to
take what we think works in cloud
kitchens and bring it to a platform that
is cheaper and more flexible and is
capable of moving where demand is
essentially using a version of food
trucks in creating essentially a
platform for companies large food brands
to launch fleets of and manage them
integrate them with online order systems
so we're really all over the place
hardware and software and are incredibly
opportunistic and it's what makes it so
fun is kind of applying horizontal
thinking to different areas and seeing
where we're crossover is where can we
cross pollinate and when we can't get to
an idea ourselves who are the right
founders to be backing and helping build
it out it's super cool and it feels like
once you have people who have done it
once or twice I mean that's really is
what made Silicon Valley Silicon Valley
or it was kind of the institutional
knowledge and the ability for everyone
not to have to solve every problem for
the first time and just hey look I've
done this six times here's what you
should do here's what you should avoid
keep going it sounds like you guys have
kind of try to institutionalize that or
at least kind of wrap yourselves around
these companies that fair yeah yeah and
I think that's a great way to put it I
mean a lot of the ways in which I like
to think about venture Studios and why I
think maybe some of them go into certain
failure modes I think one of the common
ones is right around this institutional
knowledge and that the key problem
you're solving as a venture studio is
one finding an idea that's a compelling
enough narrative that you attract
talented people but then also making
sure you're attracting talented people
who skillset you can compliment I think
that it's very common for venture
studios to go after go after people who
are experienced entrepreneurs or just
post MBAs as opposed to someone who's
been operating in an industry for the
last 10 years has never hired an
engineering team never raised venture
capital never been exposed to it and
when you go after those people and say
look like bring your knowledge bring
real relationships bring your expertise
will complement what's that
institutional called quote unquote
Silicon Valley s knowledge of a
fundraising hiring technical talent all
these things I think in you when do you
end up in a place that's that's
incredibly symbiotic and you're really
capable of like one pulling new talent
who may have been more risk-averse into
an area where they can really thrive and
you provide the capital and expertise to
help them grow and so it's really
exciting because I think it's it's still
an underrated opportunity
and I think that your Studios once they
start to build this muscle are gonna be
able to do more and more of it for sure
a lot of people don't know this but I
think what sequoias very first fund I
think they have like nine investments so
don't hold me the exact numbers but this
is directionally correct they have like
nine investments in it two of which they
incubated internally and it was like 80%
of the returns that they drove in that
first fund which have like up you know
fifty percent IRR or whatever it was
came from the two company that they
incubated internally and so everyone
knows them as kind of hey we go find
companies and invest capital but
actually I think it was Sequoia their
start was all around really they had the
two big hits were things that they
hadn't committed internally along with
funding yeah I mean I think people like
they underestimate just how much much
value there is in the creation phase
even though it's so obvious that when
the founder owns a large kind of equity
upfront and they're able to scale a
company like almost regardless of where
it exits post a hundred million phase
they're they're making reasonable
amounts and if you're able to
conceptualize that conceptualize the
idea capture some of that common stock
the returns are incredible and you're
not dealing with some of the challenges
of operating as a traditional VC
investor you're not dealing with the
challenges of operating and auction
mechanisms where if it's a really good
idea you're kind of competing on price
with any other fund out there and I
think that like one of it's interesting
because I think this is something that
another thing that people haven't really
internalized as much in terms of cap
tables but traditionally when you look
at a cap table there's a huge difference
between founder equity positions and
first employees and I think that people
intuitively understand that there's
diminishing marginal returns to to the
value of like the marginal dollar well
that actually happens on a cap table too
and I think people don't realize that
you could have a founder with 40 percent
you could bring them down to 20 percent
and they still feel fully incentivized
and a part of that company if you bring
it down to ten percent that's actually a
bigger change even though the percentage
of equity change is less and so that
leaves room and opportunity for funds or
people who are building these type of
venture studios to capture some of that
equity that is undervalued by the
founders and not going to the first
employees and still create room for for
top quality people to build really
incredible companies and I think that I
think this is the stuff where venture
capitalists figured out a lot of the
funding side of things
and this knowledge will sort of start
getting out there on the venture studio
side is more and more founders exit they
start doing their own versions of this
want to scale their entrepreneurial
leverage have diversified that's moving
from concentrated wealth building to
diversified wealth or preservation in a
skill that they know how to do for sure
make sense so we got connected because
you were tweeting all kinds of things
that when I first saw it sounded
ridiculous and then I read kind of your
explanation behind and I said wait a
minute
that guy's actually got a ton of really
interesting ideas and and may be onto
something here it sounds like you read
Nathan Bush Shaw's health OS write up
which was talking about kind of the
intersection of Apple the technology
company and all the things they could do
in healthcare etc and then you with had
this thread about like apples gonna
basically solve the longevity problem
right so again kind of at the on sets
like that sounds crazy
perfect so maybe let's just start with
like Apple as a business and kind of
what some of the it's weird calling them
structural issues given how how
successful Apple is but just the things
that are kind of on the horizon in terms
of why they would be incentivized to
pursue other things in what they're
doing today yeah yeah so I guess to
start kind of laying the groundwork we
can well go to like the highest level
and look at Apple kind of over the last
20 years in terms of how they've
developed from a hardware company
services company and then get into the
Tim Cook health company thesis so early
on Apple developing incredible hardware
first in PCs and now in mobile phones
and they were able to kind of create
this solution that was successful both
in the US and then iteratively and
market after market after market and if
you watch their growth essentially it
was incredibly predictable over a very
long period of time where each quarter
they were breaking record after record
after record and that essentially that
cadence was they were expanding to a
country after country after country and
if you've looked at the earth you
quickly realized that the earth earth is
in fact finite and they're going to run
out of countries at some point and once
you've saturated all those countries and
the people in those countries have all
bought iPhones all of a sudden you have
to think okay where are we going next
and the next place to naturally monetize
that is like okay we're not we're not
just a hardware come
or services company so you have our
devices now we're going to monetize you
ever more and more and more and more on
those devices now I think like I don't
think I put this in the thread but the
way I conceptualize what's kind of been
going on in terms of like the broad tech
ecosystem is that Apple Google Facebook
Netflix every other social media company
tik-tok every product is essentially
going after what what I'm gonna call
like vertical time so there's 24 hours
in a day how much of that can your
company capture and monetize and that's
like a really finite game that they're
playing and this is the whole Apple
services narrative is that we provide
you with the hardware we're going to be
most effective at providing you with
high quality services and products that
you want to spend money on and pay your
attention ship ok there's only a finite
amount of that again how do you kind of
get out of this trap once you've locked
people into the services and into your
hardware products there's another axis
which is horizontal which is every
single day you have 24 hours to monetize
people's attention and have them pay for
services and as it gets ever harder to
compete for the marginal service or
marginal amount attention there's room
to say ok if our customers are really
locked in which they feel like they are
I'm looking at an iPad a Mac product air
pods
I have an Apple watch on I don't think
I'm going anywhere anytime soon then
you're like ok is it easier to compete
for the marginal attention within the
day or to extend the number of days that
we can monetize this customer for now
how do you do that well this is kind of
like the whole crux of Apple solving the
human longevity problem is that if they
are the ones that are building out the
ecosystem of products like the Apple
watches the health apps all these things
that are collecting data from ancillary
devices your peloton bike your aura ring
your 8 sleep mattress all the things
that the quote unquote tech Pro is using
nowadays then all of a sudden you have a
country or sorry a a company that is
capable of kind of collecting the the
data that is necessary for being a very
effective R&D biotech company and I
think you you naturally start getting to
the conclusion that if they do have all
this data if they are the company that's
best positioned to flex a massive hour
d budget and a massive amount of like
short-term assets I think they have a
hundred billion dollars as of today what
what would you do with it what is the
biggest bet you can make and I think
Amazon is saying go to space and I think
Apple is saying extend life and I think
this is like the incredibly interesting
high level narrative of the massive tech
companies at this point yet what's super
interesting about this is I completely
agree that at some point you kind of run
out of countries to expand to your point
about you've got to extend that LTV
you're basically chasing growth right
and I think that they've although they
may not have explicitly said it they
understand that the hard word the
hardware game is going to be very hard
and also gonna get commoditized over
time so that's been kind of the shift in
does into services so they do less
talking about the like what we're not
gonna do it I do much more talk about
like hey look at this new shiny thing
that we're presenting and if you look in
the health space there's two key things
that I think are really interesting so
I've got Apple watch absolute game
changer in terms of you start caring
about things that you never cared about
like all of a sudden I started looking
at like damn I only stuff seven hours
and 30 minutes and it's the beta right
like movement I think every one before
you are actually tracking it you don't
care you don't know why any would care
but then you do start to realize like
wait a minute I feel a little bit more
you know cranky today right or I'm a
little bit more on edge like only stuff
7 hours and 10 minutes last night I
probably should sleep more and so I
think that's like just by having the
piece of hardware on your wrist
there's the like tracking so you get
sleep you get heart rate you get steps
you know all that kind of stuff but then
the first time that I started to think
of Apple as potentially being like a
real player in the healthcare space is
when I started to see that you couldn't
go in and actually change one of the
settings to give you notifications I
think it's for like a heart for like
your regular arrhythmia yeah exactly
yeah and there was like somebody who
turned it on and they see you know they
got the alert right they went to the
hospital they're like basically if you
hadn't had this alert go off like you
could have died right and you start to
realize like I think the the kind of
over-generalized
tech bro world like everybody just wants
to count their steps know what their
heart rate is you know maybe brag to
their friends who slept more hours you
know whatever
but if you start to actually use that
data to your point and actually create
true healthcare benefit that is a whole
other sector of a business then I think
previously people just didn't even
realize what it was possible to access
for a hardware company like Apple is
that fair yeah you know it's absolutely
fair and I think like what what's
incredibly interesting about Apple is
just like you just you start to see from
a strategic level the value of their
whole privacy safety and security
narrative and that healthcare data is
the most sensitive data and sitting at
the center of this kind of integration
layer with with with your Apple watch
your aura ring even like the 23andme is
like genetic data all of these things
are going to get started fun a little
funneled into this kind of centralized
repository and just because you have it
there Apple is going to be able to
surface these insights to you they're
gonna be able to nudge you in the right
direction and it's kind of like it
reminds me of like language is like once
you learned a new word all of a sudden
you see it everywhere and you start
using it everywhere and right now we're
getting a new language for healthcare
and it's called it's like the
quantitative self and it's not something
that is just limited to the biohackers
this is something that we're all going
to be able to use you're you're not
going to go to your doctor's appointment
if you're doing it at all in person but
you may be virtually you're not gonna
say I feel this way I think I have an
ache in my knee they're gonna say I did
1,000 steps this Monday that was
abnormal I had a slight heart arrhythmia
that was at this rate what's going on
and they're gonna look at your past
history they're gonna contextualize it
based on your genetics you may be
wearing a glucose monitor and saying
okay your dietary consumption was a
little bit off you've moved out of
ketosis or whatever it is I love a
sudden it's a it's a very different
place and I think Apple is one of the
few if not the only large large tech
company that we trust enough to give all
this information to because they keep on
telling us this is going nowhere that's
incredibly powerful and I think that I
mean I I just I think it's it's really
interesting when you just think about
how much stagnation it feels like
there's been in human longevity and I
think it's because we've maxed out the
point at which are just pure knowledge
of health can go and now we need to help
bring people and bring just
more information and data to bear so
that you can take this knowledge and
understanding and actually apply it
because we have that we don't have to
sit in the hospital or a lab or a Sleep
Center in order to get gather the
necessary information for any individual
to get the insights to improve their
life yeah this idea of the quantitative
self is a super interesting to me
because I think there's a piece of this
that is definitely like the obsessive
person right they want to know
everything about everything but when you
put it in the context of hey you're a
machine if you're able to give the
doctor the diagnosis right but the
diagnosis isn't kind of a point in time
and it depends on what's your blood
pressure today and did you have coffee
beforehand or did you get a doughnut or
you know whatever instead they could say
listen over the last six months when I
didn't see you here is your average
resting heart rate here is you know the
the kind of variability to that hey when
you work out your you know sleep
improves like all of those things now
just become a math equation right and
kind of a data problem on top of that
though it there's actually a mindset
shift cuz now sudden if my doctor says
to me hey you need an Apple watch
because your Apple watch is gonna give
me the information I need to be able to
take care of you everyone go buy Apple
watches right or you know you kind of go
step further whatever other diagnostic
type thing it just feels like the
healthcare kind of perspective people
are much more willing to make consumer
decisions if their doctor tells them to
do it versus if they see a cool ad on
television
yeah I mean like if you think Apple
Walken is is big now because you want to
have the blue bubbles on iMessage now
imagine you want to be able to live
longer and like you're like oh yeah I
think I'm probably gonna keep on buying
the Apple product and I'm not gonna mid
life give up all my data to switch to
another system it's like and I think
like this is the crazy part is that I
think that we're gonna get to the point
where you don't you don't choose Android
or iOS or between any of these kind of
like dichotomies of systems you're just
gonna be born into it my mom was an
iPhone user
I need her genetic information I need
her health stuff because that's relevant
to me therefore I'm going to continue
using it and there's no reason for Apple
to not integrate all these things now
Apple is notoriously bad at figuring out
that people have more than one kind of
significant other and things like that
on their products but maybe they can
sort that out and all of a sudden you
see like okay yeah there's actually even
values in like a lineage of people using
iOS or Apple for their health
information because what are your
doctors say like the first time you go
in and fill out the intake form did your
grandpa have diabetes does he have
Alzheimer's Apple's gonna know all of
that for the entire history of your
family and that is like incredibly
important because you essentially have
the blueprint for what's going to happen
to you they're gonna be able to overlay
what's going on in any individual
incident with what's happened to people
in your kind of past also people kind of
cross their data set using differential
privacy to see like oh yeah you're
similar to this person they took these
actions you should do this and because
they can do it in the privacy preserving
nature I think that is like incredibly
profound and I think this is like where
I mean the Tim Cook quote that like what
Apple is going to be remembered for for
mankind is a health company starts to
really really make sense yeah they
obviously have a ton of cash does this
mean that they start to deploy that cash
in acquisitions and go get the you know
or a ring or eight sleep mattress or
something like that
or is it more the Apple way to look at
those products say we can do it better
and try to do everything internally yeah
so it's interesting because I think I
think this is potentially where Nathan's
and i's opinion diverge in terms of the
piece he wrote is that he kind of
explores the idea that Apple is only
gonna sit at this this data layer and
that people are going to be developing
the ancillary hardware products and
feeding data into it or the primary care
physician all these things
and that's where they're just really
gonna play and sit I think that's that's
largely true but in terms of the cash
deployment I don't think they ultimately
get into developing all of the ancillary
hardware I think they actually go into
the hard biotech questions so like okay
how do I make a glucose monitor that
doesn't have to penetrate the epidermal
layer so it doesn't have to go through
years yeah I think they're gonna like if
you look at the structure of like an
Apple versus of Google Google is
incredibly good at taking data and doing
incremental development cycles what
Apple is incredibly good at is taking
information and intuition putting a
bunch of money into it and producing the
thing people need a lot that sounds much
more similar to how biotech companies
operate or drug development companies
you have to pour tons of R&D data in or
money in you have to kind of use data
and there's no incremental progress
really like you just need to get to the
step function change and so I think
where apples gonna gonna spend that
money potentially is on on those hard
healthcare challenges of like how do you
how do you develop these these sensors
and devices that are really doing the
the challenging monitoring that is
impossible now how do you kind of
deliver those insights and do the
analytics and correlate that data to
help people live longer I think that's
where they're gonna start deploying it I
think that you may see it and like I
don't know why there wouldn't be Apple
healthcare clinics like if you're going
in there you have all your data you want
to trust them you don't want Apple
giving it to a third party they already
make it abundantly clear they they don't
want you doing that given all the the
terms and services things you have to do
with an application now I think that's
only going to increase and we all love
the experience of what Apple provides
and we trust them so I think that they
are going to build out the care delivery
and hard kind of tech research or
biotech research that'd be my guess and
in terms of where a lot of this capital
may go because those are the harder
problems and the big step function
changes in value that I think they can
then uniquely have a muscle to flex
against yeah and I guess what Apple
bought nest if I remember correctly
right mm-hmm yeah yeah it was then right
yeah I might have Google yeah you might
be right I have no idea you know I
actually don't know either we should
have looked at it beforehand but let's
just say that they had done that I guess
part of it then becomes do you as you go
through
these acquisitions so eat sleep or
whatever there's also this question of
like the Apple culture right mate maybe
in contrast to some of these companies
especially Chinese that are using
physical hardware to also gather data
and sorry I wonder if integration is one
of the most important aspects of a
acquisition do you get in a world where
Apple basically says hey I'm gonna buy
these companies I'm gonna take their
products and I'm going to install like a
leader from Apple that to run them
moving forward or do you actually start
to acquire these companies and say we're
going to help these CEOs continue to run
the companies as divisions of Apple but
we're going to instill you know kind of
the nuances of apples culture around
data privacy and things like that that's
there yeah it's interesting cuz it's
kind of the question of what like what
is on the inside versus the outside of
the Apple world and like what is the
line and I think I think there's like a
very interesting kind of train of
thought there in terms of how how can
they how can they play in this Hardware
game without necessarily need to to
acquire and integrate companies which
definitely hasn't been clearly something
they're good at or they've done a lot of
obviously because they're sitting on so
much cash but I think like what's
interesting and this is this is a
totally raw thought that I'm just kind
of thinking about but they're now going
into the whole Apple silicon movement
right and could there be a world where
as opposed to just using Apple silicon
to only power Apple devices or that's
your Apple watch your iPad or your
MacBook could they start allowing
companies to use Apple silicon in their
products and that Apple silicon would
run in a certain way you would have all
the privacy preserving properties it
would do all these things they could
have the sensing mechanisms that do
certain things and those become
commoditized and they're essentially
enabling a hardware ecosystem using some
of their knowledge in doing what what I
guess Intel was doing for the last kind
of 30 years but in a way that integrates
directly into the Apple ecosystem in a
way that they they control I think that
that's potentially interesting but yeah
I think why I think I still my gut lies
with the idea that they're going to be
going after the things that are that
take billions of dollars to invest in
and pull off and it's not clear that
like like the oaring is something that
is a very cool product but you don't
need
millions of dollars to figure out how to
put those sensors on it's largely a
design problem of making it look good
whereas like if they're going to build
glasses like that that's an incredibly
hard problem these new Bluetooth
headphones with spatial audio I think
that those are the areas where Apple is
going to focus and I think it's like
honestly to bring it back to I guess one
of my favorite kind of VC isms from from
Josh wolf but I think Apple is going to
play really seriously on the kind of the
idea of like the the half-life of
technological intimacy so I think they
are going to be the ones that try and
bring the technology closer and closer
and closer to you and anything that is
doing that is something that's in
Apple's purview especially as it relates
to help so I don't see the ordering as
being any closer to you to the app than
the Apple watch or the air pods they're
gonna cover like your senses with your
eyes and Apple glasses do they get to
the point where they're measuring things
internally like glucose monitoring that
seems like a natural next step in terms
of technological intimacy but that's
that's where I'd imagine they they go
next and I think that's where the most
value is and the hardest problems are so
to avoid any confusion I looked it up
Google bot nest so anyone listening just
completely forget that what we thought
that maybe Apple had done that so you're
talking a lot about technology becoming
more intimate I think that's a foregone
conclusion if this poem we're watching
it happen in real time that then leads
to two questions one do we get
embeddable x' from Apple whether it's
like the neural link style that the
super-sexy that got to put something in
our brains and does it look maybe
something more like I know Google's got
like the glucose monitoring in the
contact lens that they can put do we get
so they get in the bloodstream whatever
and I'm thinking more of like actual
silicon or hardware technology but then
also do you look at something like
biotech right is where it's like a drug
yes technically that is technology is a
different type of technology but do they
ever enter into that field so kind of
how do you think about things actually
go in the body and what Apple could do
there yeah I think that's like the next
big barrier and I think it's I think
it's what surprised me as I would have
said yes but seeing kind of companies
like control labs kind of being able to
pull off some kind of direct brain
interface just through your arm is is
pretty promising and I think there will
all
always be a reticence to install
technology directly in an area where you
can't remove it without a third party
being involved I think that's like a new
level of trust that we haven't
necessarily got to obviously going back
to biohackers there's some people doing
things like this I consider myself kind
of someone who definitely is super into
the quantified self I would be pretty
reticent to put something into my brain
at this point it would have to be very
proven out and it's just like it's one
of those things where we haven't done it
done enough of it for for me to
necessarily feel confident in it now I
think that like I think that in terms of
where Apple will go is I think they'll
stay on the periphery of the senses and
kind of covering with like the Apple
glasses I think that I think that will
get better and better at providing
sensing mechanisms that can can sit
above the skin and I think that I think
that we still have so far to go in that
that it's not necessary at this point to
think that we need to be able to do
something embeddable now I think what
people often think about embeddable
stuff they go great directly to the
brain and the brain computer interface I
think if I were to say where is it most
likely that that'll go first is actually
in the microbiome and the gut I think
it's incredible just what a lack of
knowledge we have and in terms of how
food affects us Blue Coast monitoring is
like kind of step one in that we have no
idea like you and I could eat an apple
and respond entirely differently you
could eat an apple after an avocado and
I do it after an orange and it's just
like totally different results and we
have what I think are kind of poor
heuristics for optimal diet which is
like I'm gonna follow keto I'm gonna
follow paleo I'm gonna follow whatever
and to me that's just people saying I
don't know what works
I need something to follow and I'm gonna
pick one that's kind of good you would I
think like to kind of give it a
comparison you would never say like I'm
going to pick like this theme for my
room and use only the pre picked out
things for my room because those it just
doesn't make sense you're gonna pick the
things that you'd enjoy because you know
this is what you like and you walk in
there and you like this picture and that
lamp and you kind of pick this customize
experience that makes you feel good and
I think people kind of are intuitively
doing with that food with that with food
they want to correlate it to health so
then they're going to a proximal
solution of just let's like apply like a
bucket heuristic of keto or whatever but
ultimately like these sensing devices or
things you could like
just as a pill that can measure what's
in your microbiome I think you're gonna
allow you to say what are the things you
like taste-wise that make you feel good
what are the things you respond well to
and then using the data you gather from
the ancillary devices how does that
actually make you feel and perform and
all those things so I'd say the blood
the brain aspect I think is very far
microbiome aspect I think is much much
closer and potentially where would go
first if you're internally ingesting
things kind of all of the major tech
companies is Apple the the leader in
terms of who you would trust first to
put something inside your body I think
so I think so I think I would trust
Apple more than anyone definitely not
Netflix because I don't want to get
addicted to TV and and for sure Facebook
Google Google is Google is great I mean
maybe they give me a free thing and I
might fall for the trick but I think
Apple would be definitely be the one I'm
Trust and I've been I think there's an
argument for like I don't think they're
there yet but I mean SpaceX in my mind
has the opportunity to be like the
biggest company ever and I think they
have a clear intention and invest and
ability to invest in really hard
problems and as they explore space and
figure out what's necessary to keep and
monitor a human body in that environment
I think they also have some incentives
to do like Jeep investing in research
here and so I think it's possible that
they also produce products that are in
the stain and that might be someone I
would trust to because they essentially
have to design high performance devices
for people who aren't going to be able
to access traditional systems so that
would be maybe the other one that's not
traditionally a fan company but in my
mind could potentially produce something
interesting yeah it's also really
interesting to think about similar what
we're seeing with predictive analytics
if Apple could get into that world right
so this whole idea of you're talking
about food and how it affects us like I
almost imagine this weird feels somewhat
kind of big brother-ish world but if you
trust Apple to make your life better if
Apple was able to essentially when you
go to sleep it wakes you up when you're
ready based on your calendar and the
sleep you need it tells you hey here's
certain types of food that you should
eat today based on you know all these
different measures they've looked at
they tell you what to do from an
exercise standpoint what
it's you know hey look go for a two-mile
walk or it's something where it's like
hey look do an exercise that keeps your
you know heart rate above 100 for 30
minutes or more today like that type of
stuff and if you can almost get in this
world where and that's like apples
running your life but they are doing
things that move towards the
optimization for what you've chosen so
some people may say hey look I want to
lose weight Apple can help you some
people may want to say hey I want to
extend my life right or some people may
literally say hey I want to optimize for
efficiency so tell me the least amount
of things I need to do to hit some bare
minimum from a food and exercise
standpoint so like not make myself worse
by the end of the day right but but like
that feels like it's not short term but
it's definitely could be on the roadmap
far enough out yeah and honestly I think
you saw this the most recent WWDC
conference that they are they're
starting to really touch on that I mean
the activity Apple was was kind of the
closest but like if you kind of like go
and try and zoom out squint the eyes a
little bit they're doing these kind of
now the wedge fits there now embeddable
they have smart widgets that show you
information that is contextual to where
you are in the day the the news in the
morning the calendar at lunch and your
fitness stuff at the end of the day to
say oh maybe you should work out then
you have their movement of the sleep
where they're going to start silencing
your notifications dimming things I
think naturally it's it's it would make
sense for them to do what you're saying
and like say like here's when you should
wake up like don't even set an alarm
like why do I like you have both my
calendar and everything else like why do
I need to set the alarm to say I need to
wake up at this time Apple could very
clearly be doing that and and I think
this is where you kind of get into like
we're talking a lot about the
quantitative stuff but there's so many
soft metrics and data points that they
have like I think the calendar is
something that's totally under leverage
like theoretically you could look at my
calendar and be like what are the days
Cameron reads meditates hangs out with
friends sees family travels has a bunch
of work meetings all these things and
how do those correlate to like how I end
up feeling how I end up sleeping and I
think I think this has been like the
impossible layer that we've had to drive
like or you just use our intuition and
feeling to judge that Apple may be able
to delve into is like look like when you
have a full work calendar and you don't
work out you're in an incredibly worse
place and I think that that that is
really exciting and interesting
to me and I wish I was enough of a data
scientist to do that on my own right now
but I'm just not yeah that one of the
other pieces of this that we're seeing
other companies do Twitter for example
now is doing this thing like if you're
gonna send some you know crazy tweet
that they detect you whether it's
through language or kind of intention
they will basically put an interstitial
that says hey like hey are you sure you
want to send this like you know
basically be nice to people and it you
can click through and send it but it
just makes people stop and think for a
second I almost wonder of apically get
to the place where isn't have to like
proactively tell me what to put on my
calendar but if it knows that I'm about
to schedule the you know ninth meeting
for the day and there's no workout
planned on the calendar it says like are
you sure you want to schedule this on
days where you don't work out and you
have you know more than X number of
hours for readings then you feel like
[ __ ] and don't sleep well you know maybe
you want to switch this meeting out for
a workout like that again it's somewhat
predictive but also somewhat like the
experience these are Americans that
feels like that is a inflection point on
the individuals life they may not create
you know billions of dollar market cap
for Apple in the short term but it just
feels like that would change my
relationship with Apple and further
deepen it because I just can't get that
anywhere else yeah in it this this is
goes into like another broader thing
that I've been I've been thinking about
but like when you start going into these
software things like should you work or
should you relax should you see your
family should you go to sleep should you
work out there is like the health
component of that but there's also like
a value system component of like what
should Apple be telling you to do what
should Twitter be telling you to say and
I think this is where you get into the
this is partially where my thinking had
gone after the Apple stuff but like what
gets what happens when you start having
these companies that look like countries
in terms of your choosing to be a part
of them for your lifetime and and how or
if you're opting into their value system
and Apple chooses to prefer that you
should be spending more time with family
than then working that's a value system
choice more than than anything else and
I think we start ending up in a really
really interesting in weird place I
forget who wrote the piece but someone
came out with something there was an
important policy review about about it
was really focused on zoom but the idea
that when you have companies
that operate internationally and across
especially like China in the u.s.
they're essentially one company that has
to deal with to value systems and that
expression the to value systems is
oftentimes in massive conflict I don't
know where it goes but like apples going
to have to if they're gonna play this
game they're gonna have to choose and
codify their value system they're
essentially gonna have to have a
constitution for what it means to be a
citizen of Apple is the citizen at Apple
someone who only maximizes GDP are they
purely like a Protestant type person is
it someone that is purely focused like a
Sweden on unhappiness or something like
that those are these are like these are
more value choices and that's where you
say like oh my gosh like these companies
like like I guess we'll stick with Apple
but like Apple I think did two hundred
sixty billion dollars in revenue I'm I'm
pretty sure if you look at like the OECD
countries the only ones like above I
think Sweden is just on the barrier
honestly of like they did two hundred
sixty billion dollars in tax revenue
last year and like that that is the
scale at which Apple is operating and so
you're just starting to like blur the
line of what is possible what goods
should they be providing what value
should they be pushing and which of
these are you're gonna op into as an
individual because it really is a
lifetime decision what is your biggest
what seems like the least obvious thing
that Apple will do but you believe they
will in the next ten years but like
what's that one thing we're like people
aren't thinking about this enough but
you think it's a foregone conclusion um
I think I think it's a foregone
conclusion ma'am I do I guess like I
mean it's honestly about the whole thing
I think it's a foregone conclusion that
your primary care provider will be Apple
at some point in the future I think like
preak ovid there was a big narrative
that I think people have forgotten about
where Apple was moving their stores from
stores to town squares like they were
literally calling that like if this
isn't this is like apples colonialism of
like the u.s. like every city is gonna
have like an apple town square and if
you're telling me what do you put in a
town square you have a store for buying
the things you also have a place for
getting the health things and you have a
place for educating yourself like this
was their whole narrative I think a year
ago and they're like big announcements
was like we are manifesting Google in
the physical world beyond just a
transactional place we're a place where
get educated replace where you get the
things you need and if I think about the
stuff that government provides in a
system like that or a country it's it's
it's it's education health care and then
protection and I think they are clearly
doing education and providing the
products I think healthcare is next and
the question is like do they actually
get into the the game of violence like
do you protect these values that you
created that's the ultimate government
move they definitely on violence right
now for you before we get into a
rapid-fire round to finish up is
competition do you think that maybe
Google and Amazon are the only two who
even have the balance sheet and are
crazy and ambitious enough to even try
to compete down this path like do you
think anyone's got a shot or is that is
it pretty much Apple or we won't see
kind of consolidation like this yeah so
I think I'd write off Google and and a
lot of my roundup is based on like
short-term data I just think they've
done such a poor job with it but like if
you told me like what would be a signal
that Apple's gonna or Google's gonna do
this while I'd be like oh they bought
Fitbit they have like probably the top
wearable at this point in time other
than the Apple watch like have they been
able to do anything meaningful that
feels like you know then I think the the
Amazon question I think is more
interesting because I think that Amazon
kind of has this ability to sneak
underneath the surface and you see what
they're doing with Berkshire Hathaway in
terms of working to create a healthcare
system and I think they're slowly gonna
they're the like best bundler like
they're gonna start bundling things into
prime like once a year you get a bit of
our healthcare system for free great I
get a free checkup you can buy our
knockoff app Amazon wearable that's $20
and we'll give it to you free if you
sign up your kids for your new Prime
subscription all of a sudden you start
seeing like if the technology becomes
commoditized and you don't need to get
the high-end Apple watch you could just
opt for the Amazon basic they're gonna
provide a lot of those things as long as
you're using the Animus on basic you
walk into their stores which already
just recognized you facially handle the
transactions they're incurred you go to
creating a seamless experience around
things and so I think it's possible this
they're they're probably the ones that I
would guess could compete on next that
being said it seems like Beezus he wants
to play in the space game and not as
much in the healthcare game at least
from outward narratives and I think
those those are the two big things is
like it's like space and health and
those are the big problems these
companies should be going after so this
is a whole other episode so I won't even
go down this down this rabbit hole but
one of the things that's really amazed
me by Amazon is they're basically taking
Costco's model so you look at Costco and
scope basically sells everything at cost
and they've got $16 a year membership
fee and if you look at their bottom line
like basically if you take the number of
members they have multiplied by 60
that's how much profit they make right
and I think it's this incredible
business that's built on sixty dollars a
year per customer
Amazon obviously has many profitable
lines of business but prime looks and
feels very similar right it's basically
pay a hundred bucks a year or whatever
it is now and you get everything else
kind of behind the wall and they keep
building out value and at what point do
you get you know 80% penetration in the
u.s. of members of Prime we're not there
yet but like you know that that doesn't
seem like it's impossible
no no by no means at all and I think
like this whole bundling narrative is
set to continue right now we assume you
bundle certain things with government
and just given the size of these
companies I think a lot of that will
shift to to the the companies that
apples the Amazons of the worlds and
because they have such a clear KPI which
is shareholder returns they're gonna be
able to more be more efficient at
delivering those bundles so I think in a
lot of ways I mean this is some of the
argument for for capitalism but that's
like a more bigger conversation
absolutely I've finished up each episode
asking two questions the first one is
what is the most important book that
you've ever read so most important book
so the one that I think that I've read
that is definitely important to me that
I don't think many other people have
read would be why greatness cannot be
planned the myth of the objective by Jo
Lehmann and Kenneth Stanley they're
computer scientists and essentially they
did that they did a project exploring
like what what happens when you give
people a set of pictures just randomly
generated pictures and you let them kind
of choose this one that kind of looks
like a circle with like a square thing
and you click that and then it generates
off of that some permutations that look
similar
what they found is that through this
random exploration people would take
seemingly random permutations and
without intending to do something turn
it into an image of a car they would
then try and say like hey someone go
build an image of a car from like
clicking random things and no one could
ever get there and they said okay what
if intelligence as opposed to being some
like explicit search for with a certain
heuristic it's actually something that
is a search for for novelty like all you
do is try and do things that others
haven't done before and that's actually
the only way to end or end up somewhere
quote-unquote great because if there
were a heuristic for greatness
then you or I would just be like oh yeah
great like follow the heuristics but if
we both follow the same heuristic and we
end up in the same place then it's not
great and so they kind of have I think
this kind of goes back to the key
through boy like personal and oddly
thinking all this stuff is like how are
you going through life kind of jumping
from stone to stone in a way that puts
you in a place that others are not
aren't at because those are the places
where you at least have the potential to
end up somewhere quote-unquote great
however you want to define that and I
think it does a really good job of
exploring it I'm not sure if their
applications or algorithms actually work
in any real way but the concept itself
is something that's that's really stuck
with me I've never even heard of them
but that's an awesome suggestion second
question is a little bit more fun aliens
believer or non-believer mm-hmm
believer or non-believer I guess like
there's I guess there's the whole like
fear me like approximation answer this
question which I'm sure there's people
who can articulate that much better but
I'll try and go one thing I've been
thinking a lot about recently more on
this spiritual side of things is is the
idea and I do I forget who was it who
was popular as popularized by I believe
it was like someone a French person but
um that that consciousness is not
something emergent from our minds but
rather consciousness exists outside of
us and that our minds are just something
that experiences consciousness or is a
receiver of it kind of like your fingers
feel like they're separate but they're
all connected to something bigger and if
you say like okay like let's take that
it's true that I'm just touching in or
tapping into the same consciousness that
you're tapping into then why does it
feel does it feel intuitive that there
should be other places in the universe
that also tap into this like
consciousness in some form even if we
we feel separate like our fingers but
are in fact connected in some larger way
I find something kind of like
intellectually attractive about that and
I'll say that's a reason to believe
believe aliens you know I'll define
aliens as people that also are things
that also experience consciousness may
exist BC beyond Earth I tend to think
that the consciousness debate is is one
of these things that once you go down
that rabbit hole there's all kinds of
things about the guy I gotta take a
break I had a professor in college that
kind of led it with so much structure an
exploration of like what is
consciousness in a class and I remember
kids were Li like you know half the
class like this guy's literally nuts and
like wow you changed my life type stuff
and everyone's gonna there's a guy came
on the podcast named Bruce Fenton and
he's like an ancient alien researcher
and he basically said every human will
ask the same two questions at some point
in their life they'll ask what happens
after death and the second question
they'll ask is are we here alone and I
thought that that was like he nailed it
right like like yes those two questions
will absolutely ensure everyone's mind
could happen different times in their
life but those are the two questions man
yeah yeah no totally agree and I love
the the distillation 'he's like that and
it's yeah just really really cool and
it's fun to think about that's the whole
game absolutely to wrap up you get ask
me one question what is the one question
you have for life um one question let's
see let's go for one that I've been
asking people write or more recently but
feeling on the psychedelic movement and
the potential for it to go mainstream
what do i how do I feel about it yeah
yeah do you how do you feel about it do
you think like we're going to be in
another 60s 70s type movement or do you
think it's going to be relegated to the
large drug companies trying to figure
out how to kind of produce monetary
returns with it will it lead to kind of
a spiritual revolution of any kind
basically very open-ended but curious
for heads up yeah so
first of all came out don't think I'm
not an expert on this at all I've done
what I'll call kind of very elementary
research both in you know google ground
and things like that I've got two or
three friends that are like much more
into it so I've kind of been fortunate
enough to hear them talk about it but
not really myself and then my wife got
me to to watch this Gwyneth Paltrow goop
documentary thing where they literally
send some of their employees I can't I
don't think it was ayahuasca I think it
was something else so they did I forget
what it was but they did some kind of
psychedelic and they kind of filmed it
and uh you know the way you would expect
a Netflix type to be filmed yeah that
was interesting to kind of see what I'll
say is I think that there is no doubt
that it will happen and happen being
like there will be an industry there it
seems like it's pretty obvious that like
any medical kind of applications that
are run through like traditional
processes you know in terms of testing
and approvals and all that kind of stuff
like that's pretty much table stakes you
just gotta actually do the test and get
it approved but that seems pretty viable
in terms of like what I'll call the more
recreational stuff
I personally am of the belief that like
look if you do things in your life and
you don't hurt other people like knock
yourself out right if that makes you
happy like literally knock yourself out
and this feels like it kind of falls on
a debate of like hey I've never heard of
anyone overdosing on marijuana but like
there's a lot of people who die from
drinking too much right and so like over
generalization and they kind of equip
when people want to talk about drugs but
it's like coffees a drug alcohol is a
drug right like so don't tell me that we
can't have drugs in our life and then
when you think about it like from a
psychedelic standpoint like there's a
lot of things that you could put in your
body that change your mental state that
aren't called psychedelics right and and
so I think that when you get into that
world it's just the kind of
open-mindedness as a society to some of
this takes
and so actually one of the things that I
personally look at for in areas like
this is like how does culture change
around it so if for example do we start
to see more people putting it in rap
songs for music do we see more of it on
television or in movies like those types
of things almost then it's kind of like
marijuana at this point like everyone
knows is gonna be legal on the federal
level at some point I can't say if
that's you know this year five years or
little taste twenty years to happen but
like you have cities decriminalizing
possession of small amounts of marijuana
like okay like that's going to continue
that's a trend that's gonna be hard to
fight it feels like we're at the very
very early stages of the psychedelic
stuff the part that I don't think I
understand enough is like from an
outsider looking in with just a very
elementary understanding there's a lot
of words they get them around they're
super scary right let me start you
certain by talking about the names of
things or what they do and people just
like uh like this sounds crazy but then
when you actually understand it you know
a little bit deeper you're like oh this
is actually could be one beneficial from
medical standpoint and to is no
different than other things so I do
think that there's like this the
cultural piece is one and the other
piece is you kind of gotta make a
concerted effort to like explain why two
people who aren't necessarily like the
self-starters to go check it out but but
I would say that I definitely think it's
something that is a foregone conclusion
I'm probably just a little bit more
muddy on how do we get from where we are
today what do you think it's something
you probably thought about a little bit
more yeah so I'll I'll give you my my
ultimate hot take to tie in all the
things we talked about but I know I gave
you the answer that the inevitability
that people don't believe is that Apple
is going to build out the the primary
care facilities but we'll all throw it
out there that in the next thirty years
Apple will be the one prescribing you
LSD and it's the ultimate manifestation
of Steve Jobs having started the company
after doing LSD in college and building
this whole thing so we'll leave it at
that
you gotta give us like another minute on
how we get there
I mean basically the general idea being
like if if a lot of these things coming
out of maps and Johns Hopkins and the
various research institutions prove true
and it's in
incredibly profound way to affect
addiction and mental health and all
these other things and you have a
company that's capable of providing
health care and services and if mental
health is a core part of longevity then
it seems inevitable that your main
health care provider will provide you
with these psychedelics at some point
and they'll go down the path of
marijuana from from illegal to legal to
recognizing the health benefits
potentially I don't know but if those
things are true then if everything we've
talked about in this podcast is
something we really believe in then if
you kind of caveat with we believe
psychedelics have the potential to do
good for certain people then it seems
inevitable that Apple or could be the
one prescribing them to you in some form
in the next thirty years we say it that
way didn't sound too crazy and that's
the fun of really amorphis ideas all
right where can people find you on the
Internet and and find out more about a
li corp so simple things I'm at cam 39
quarter on Twitter and then it's just a
like or calm so real easy
what's the 39 in cam 39 Porter said so
that's so I had the pleasure of getting
verified while I was playing
professional soccer and the MLS and if
you change your name and remove the 39
then you lose your verification and so
for the rest of my life I am forever
number 39 in all endeavors then it's a
very philosophical number in no way just
randomly chosen and assigned to me as a
rookie on a team so it's very important
but I can't talk about it I love that I
love that all right man listen thank you
so much for doing this and though I'm
due to get in the future awesome really
enjoyed it